hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday December 26th
2022. oh it's the last Monday
of 2022.
um
um
yeah so I've been coughing if you guys
have noticed
for like what the last six weeks
as I finished up my tour and my uh in
the movie
and um
what the [ __ ] I haven't been coughing
all morning
I finally went to the dark I had family
come to town ate a family back East I
had the family coming to town
so uh
my wife was finally like why don't you
go to urgent care and just [ __ ] find
out what it is
you know she didn't say it like that but
that's the way I Heard It In My Head why
don't you got a pack of an urgent car I
was just like all right
I said because I'm not gonna [ __ ] sit
in a hospital for like three goddamn
hours well
well my the family baggage is out here
right I'll go tomorrow after everybody
leaves so she she says okay
so we go over there
and
um
we go over there get some water here
and they do all this [ __ ] right
they ask me all the questions and then
they took a chest x-ray and uh like it
looks good it looks clear I said okay
good
so they gave me some medicine and all
that [ __ ] I get it and then later on
that night somebody else looked at the
X-ray
and when Jesus Christ your red [ __ ]
you got pneumonia
so
that's what happens when you [ __ ]
work too much and don't go to the doctor
you end up getting pneumonia so it's a
low level
you know I'm taking the drugs I'm really
good with the drugs
like I got a lot of pills here I got an
inhaler
right
I'm going to do a cycle of [ __ ] HGH
and steroids put on some Mass maybe do a
little Botox this is Hollywood pneumonia
treatment by the way
um
get some hair plugs
you know what I mean
just come back but celebrities how do
they bounce back from pneumonia so fast
according to Bill burry did it all
naturally
tipping the scales at 210 pounds of
solid muscle
it's really hilarious
how [ __ ] jacked you have to be now
to be an action star man
I mean it's insane you just back in the
day you just had to look like you could
[ __ ] somebody up
you know but I also think back in the
day a lot of those guys
fought in World War II in Korea and they
had actually lit like legitimately
killed people
you know a lot of the guys like I
remember like Lee Marvin
was like one of two people that survived
in his platoon
so like when that guy had a gun in his
hand and [ __ ] gave you the look I
mean he didn't have to be all [ __ ]
roided up
to make you believe that he could [ __ ]
somebody up because you know this guy
had bodies
[Laughter]
so
um I was watching
um oh geez oh geez my son's freaking out
oh boy
oh boy
doing the podcast in the house as you
can see I gotta check that in on this
all right I'm back
older wiser BB I almost gave my wife
[ __ ] being like hey honey I'm trying to
do a podcast here in the house
why is our toddler acting like a toddler
you know
stop myself and I said Bill why don't
you go out to the garage
you know sit next to your drums and
finish this [ __ ] thing so
um
so anyway
um yeah turns out I had [ __ ]
pneumonia
and uh low level low level everybody
relax
you know the band's not playing on here
um
I'll be all right
so uh yeah that's the deal I'll tell you
underrated underrated low-level
pneumonia
gives you the excuse to [ __ ] lay
around in a bed and nobody can give you
[ __ ] God knows your wife's still going
to ask you to do [ __ ]
you know she was still asking me to do
[ __ ] and I just kept looking at her
going I have pneumonia
and I just stare at her as I'd smile and
get up to go do whatever the [ __ ] she
wanted you know
it's hilarious you know my whole
stand-up career I've always heard like
uh female Comics have always been doing
these bits talking about what babies
guys are when they get sick oh my God
they're such [ __ ] babies and I
remember hearing that you know you know
[ __ ] German irish guys I'm not going
to be a baby when I get [ __ ] sick
you ain't gonna [ __ ] do those jokes
about me woman right
so
um
now now that I've gotten pneumonia and
my wife is still having me move the kids
table from downstairs up the flight of
[ __ ] stare you know
it was funny like I when the guy came
back and said you have pneumonia my
wife's like see I [ __ ] told you I
told you I knew there was something more
going on so she gets to do the dude I
call it called it like I knew you had
[ __ ] pneumonia or something
and then continues
to give me the uh the honey honey do
list
it's like what the f I got [ __ ] the
mode when do I get a day off from this
[ __ ]
unbelievable
I'm [ __ ] believable so now I'm
looking at that thing
because when I heard the ladies going
guys are such [ __ ] babies when they
get sick I would I took that as fact
like oh I guess we're a bunch of [ __ ]
I should [ __ ] not be a [ __ ] when I
get sick and now there's another side of
it where I'm still thinking guys might
be babies when they get sick but there's
another side too where I think women
they
they don't like when you get sick
because now they can't just [ __ ]
order you around to do [ __ ]
you know like if they have to go get you
God forbid a couple of [ __ ]
Alka-Seltzer over there
you know what it is with these broads oh
come on Bill it's the day after
Christmas I don't give a [ __ ]
um
this is what it is with these broads
there Mo some of them not all of them
not the Sweethearts
the [ __ ]
the ones you know you know that broad
one of your buddies from your [ __ ]
crew
married her
all right no matter how big how small
your crew is
I don't know how this works out but like
one of them at some point in their life
is gonna marry a [ __ ]
and it is what it is and if you're
sitting there going like well no one in
my crew married a [ __ ] that's because
you married the [ __ ]
here's some signs
here's some signs to know if you're the
one that married the [ __ ] uh
do your friends sort of avoid eye
contact with you
when she's around
do they have a sad
look on their face as though they're
remembering in easier time
um anyway so I think like there's a
certain segment of guys that are [ __ ]
when they're sick
[ __ ] babies right
I will attest to that right if I use
that word I'm not I mean I will agree to
that is what I'm trying to say I just
said I will attest to that because I
heard other human beings say I will
attest to that in a similar social
situation but I have no idea what it
means I will look it up
actually I won't
I would just say that I will
um but I think there's also another
group of women who are just selfish and
I know you're not supposed to say that
because they're women and they're Brave
and they're Heroes and they're [ __ ]
the reason why there wouldn't be War if
they were running [ __ ] or whatever
whatever it says in their [ __ ]
[ __ ] pamphlet
you know there's more lies in the
woman's pamphlet than a [ __ ]
Community College pamphlet you know back
in the day when I do stand up at
colleges these [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
community colleges could always figure
out how to be number one in something
where we have the greatest asphalt of
any parking lot with people with a lower
than a 1.7 grade point average
in the 798 area code
Southwest
of my desk over to that wall
um yeah there's just some women out
there that they're just the star of the
show
okay they're not paying for nothing they
hold the door the husband gets [ __ ] for
them and they're just running the deal
and when they get a husband they don't
look at them as much as a life partner
as they now have a sort of a
a free personal assistant slash Butler
slash repairman
and when that dude goes down
the woman like turns into like Bill
Parcells or an old school head football
coach
and it's she just has one question while
you're sick can you go
you know and you only have one answer
yes I can put me in coach what do you
need me to do where am I going huh
am I picking up dry cleaning am I going
over to the [ __ ] uh goddamn uh Home
Depot
to get some [ __ ] Nativity [ __ ] what
am I doing
um
yeah
my wife had a Christmas dinner that was
amazing it was all set up
and she had in her head what I needed to
do to help out
come hell or pneumonia she didn't give a
[ __ ] so you know
every time I went to sit down
she'd be like oh honey can you do me can
you put the star on the tree
it's like you can't get up on a [ __ ]
step ladder and do that I have pneumonia
kept saying
I just kept going I have pneumonia
why don't I said a low level of it as
you can tell
um
now she didn't order me around that bed
I'm being a [ __ ] baby but I will say
this had I married a [ __ ] which I didn't
like that would have been the thing
um so there you go so that that Urban
myth is dispelled it's dispelled it's
displaced is attested to
um
is uh
um what do they call it what do they
call it when white people move into a
neighborhood
um
Trader Joe joeing what do they call it
gentrification
that's the word I needed pneumonia
gentrification
um
no I think that Urban myth I think some
guys it's a spectrum like everything is
everything's a spectrum
it that that line that guys are babies
when they get sick is all the way from a
hundred percent true
that you unfortunately married a big
baby
you know which I gotta be honest with
you I don't even understand that
you know how are you a big baby if
you're sick that that would be if you're
not sick and you're overly dramatizing
dramatizing it
dramatically uh allies in it right I
would say it's that but like when my
wife gets sick she's just like [ __ ] this
and she goes to bed and she She lays
there and does what she's supposed to do
and she gets over it quick I don't think
she's a baby I think she's smart I think
I'm an idiot
right where I just keep plowing ahead
huh
finishing my [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's just a [ __ ] flesh wound
it's pneumonia you [ __ ] red [ __ ]
you know what's amazing on my x-right
chest x-ray I actually have freckles on
my lungs too like that's how much of a
ginger I am
to the Bone [ __ ]
um
so I think it's all the way from guys
actually being babies
to just
um
cold selfish women
who are annoyed that their husband slash
personal assistant can no longer do [ __ ]
around the house and they actually have
to go fetch things
honey could you do me a favor and get me
an alka-seltzy there
oh my God you're such a [ __ ] baby
just [ __ ] drink this are you still
sick
okay but I'm just letting you know
there's a whole bunch I set that down
here
I'm sorry honey I'm trying to get better
quicker
so that's what I learned
um
I learned that my wife
is an angel
however
if there's a holiday dinner
planned she doesn't give a [ __ ] if you
have pneumonia
you know
all of that [ __ ] that light bulb's got
to get done that table's gonna get
brought up the stars going on the
[ __ ] tree
which I never did by the way
I bought this beautiful tree that I
didn't realize had Polio on top
this [ __ ] thing was all crooked and
[ __ ] I was just like oh and they had
tight you know why because they tied a
string
they'd done some like used car lot [ __ ]
and they tied the string to make it
[ __ ] straight
um
which by the way did you know having a
bent dick is actually a problem
I didn't know that
when I was growing up hey how's it
hanging a little bit of left a little to
the right now all of a sudden they're
calling it like uh yeah it's like you
blew out your ACL and your [ __ ] shaft
now they have an operation
you know
I don't know Megan the stallions seem to
like those kinds of dicks According to
some of her rhyming and timing on on the
one and two over there
you know what's funny is I listen to all
of that [ __ ] because I like the drums
and that's usually at a temple that you
can kind of like try out some fills and
[ __ ]
so I I listeners I'm that [ __ ]
always been that [ __ ] will still be
that [ __ ] you know every tense of [ __ ]
um anyway
cardi B
who else do I listen to I told you I've
been listening to all this stuff be ya
I think that's that's about as deep as I
go that's not bad
for 54 and a half year old white guy
with no hair and pneumonia
during the holidays it's the holiday
season
did you get the [ __ ] that you thought
you wanted and now you don't have a
[ __ ] place for it
oh wouldn't it be nice if you got
nothing then you wouldn't have to pack
it up every [ __ ] time you had to move
why did I need this in every color
um
I always think that's hilarious when
they go into those uh
the celebrity walk-in closets
like first of all it does anything
scream new money than actually allowing
a camera crew to go through your whole
[ __ ] house is that got to be the
dumbest thing you could ever do
I always just feel like thieves are
watching at home going like this has to
be entrapment there's no way there's not
going to be a cop there why would you be
so [ __ ] stupid to give me the entire
layout of your house and what you have
in it
because I I live in a gated community I
I didn't think you could get past the
gate
there's literally a show on Netflix can
you believe it
Netflix has some [ __ ] content the
content Kings
um they had a [ __ ] show on there
where it was like these guys that were
like robbing celebrity houses
and they actually were show making the
thieves sort of like the heroes of it
and they were kind of going like uh this
is how you do it
this is how dumb these people are
she left her [ __ ] door open we went
there three times she had so much [ __ ]
she didn't even notice
and she [ __ ] locked it one time we
were like ah [ __ ] she she had a key
under the mat
you think if you were in a gated
community you could do the [ __ ] key
under the mat right
I don't know
that's when you need Kevin Costner is
your bodyguard right isn't that what
that movie was about
and I the eye
um sorry I actually tried to go higher
than that my voice was just like and not
happening
all right so
let's talk
oh you know what I got for Christmas
something that I said I didn't want and
my wife went out and got it anyway
she got me one of those espresso
cappuccino makers and I was like are you
out of your [ __ ] mind
you know how I am I can't bring the
devil in the house
the greatest thing about
my new Addiction of coffee is I have to
go out and get it if I can just [ __ ]
sit here making this [ __ ]
let me [ __ ] up all night
oh you're not gonna do that you just
[ __ ]
just make it in the morning
honey that's how you're wired
you know
you know what the reality is is I looked
into getting one of those those uh
[ __ ] machines not only were they like
a zillion dollars
like there's a it's not he just there's
a whole like skill set
you know if they taste a little burnt
that's because you're grinding them up
too much you need to back it off a
little bit
and
I was like oh
now I get why all the Baristas wear
those knitted hats
they're holding their brains in
trying to figure out
how to make the perfect [ __ ] espresso
and I saw that and I was like I I don't
want to I don't wanna
I don't want to take that on
I can go right down the street and for
two three bucks
I can have a master Barista make me an
espresso I can be out in the sun I can
sit down at a table I can rub my chin as
people watch me drink it and they go
there's a man who's a heavy thinker
right and what I'm really thinking is is
how the [ __ ] did the Titans not cover
over Houston not only that they actually
lost the [ __ ] game who are the Texans
there is [ __ ] confusing to me as the
Carolina Panthers right now
and I'm not even going to bring up the
Lions
who I was told are the real deal on
Thanksgiving
but people don't know I'm thinking that
they think I'm [ __ ] you know
designing an electric car
I mean I'm at a coffee shop right I am a
white person at a coffee shop of a
certain age not dressing my age
right there you know
for all you non-whities listen to that
that status
that that's street cred in the white
Community you know I don't know what how
it goes down
I don't know what the flavor is on your
side of the street okay but on my
vanilla latte side of the street
if you want [ __ ] respect respects out
here in these streets yeah you got to
get yourself uh
some sort of outfit that says you work
with your hands even though people know
you don't
you know
have yourself a little bushy facial hair
or something and you sit down and you
drink some espresso
okay
and then when you rub your chin you
can't do it too many times
it has to be a nicely timed
you know looking across the street at
nothing and you rub your chin
and then all the other whities look over
and wear like that guy
that guy's doing [ __ ] that guy's balling
oh man what's he doing over there is he
creating an assisted reality show
um
sorry I'd love to blame the medication
but it's doing wonders for me
um
anyway
I'm laying on the floor of my drum room
it's [ __ ] great
because you know what I don't have [ __ ]
to do
I have nothing to do
today
um except take my pneumonia medication
did I mention I have pneumonia that was
one of my favorite jokes I heard in a
movie growing up guy was on the phone
and the lady was like b or d and he was
like no P like pneumonia I thought that
was a very great that was a very funny
joke
that steered me into the the world of
telling [ __ ] jokes see
um yeah I don't have any road gigs until
[ __ ] April
and um
that is an amazing thing
uh which by the way people ask him to go
well what about you Patricia O'Neill
benefit
um that is got pushed a little bit that
and I think that that's going to be in
April we should have a lineup soon
that's still happening
for those of you out there wondering
which I really appreciate that people
care enough after 10 years of doing this
um that should be happening in April uh
let's talk [ __ ] New England Patriots
football
if you follow me on Twitter I live
tweeted throughout the whole [ __ ]
second half saying the [ __ ] wasn't over
saying we had the Bengals right where we
wanted them and everybody was going
Billy you're drinking again Bill are you
[ __ ] taking it in the ass you know
it's the [ __ ] internet they're always
going to go [ __ ] homophobe [ __ ] right
all of this stuff right
and lo and behold
we made our halftime adjustments
we settled the [ __ ] down
and we came right back against a very
good Cincinnati Bengal team we had the
[ __ ] game in our control our destiny
we let him off the hook
second [ __ ] week in a row
that's what kills me
that's what keeps me up at night
not the inequality of society
not global warming
not the senseless violence
or child labor
what keeps me up at night
is how the [ __ ] we lost to the Raiders
and the Bengals these past two [ __ ]
weeks
unbelievable
um
I will say
that Jones kid number 25 is a [ __ ]
Superstar
on defense and there's a lot of
positives on the defensive side of the
ball
um
you know we just
it's actually good then we lost these
last two games because I don't really
want to make the playoffs as much as I
want to have
um
some draft picks
right
that's kind of where I'm at with the
team Mac Jones Mac Jones me
foreign
ER
he's got a thing
below the knee
he had another below the knee [ __ ]
hit that guy better watch out man
that is his third
piece of [ __ ] move of the year I'm
trying to ride with this guy
he [ __ ] lost a fumble and grabbed the
linebackers
sorry I knew singing would [ __ ] me up um
or attempting to sing
um
he lost a fumble
um
earlier this year and as he was going
down the ground he just grabbed the
guy's leg the linebacker that stripped
him and just [ __ ] turned it the guy
collapsed to the ground I was like what
the [ __ ] is that
it's like right out of the WWE Captain
Lou Albano wouldn't do some [ __ ] like
that
then he had his Infamous quarterback
slide where he should have got [ __ ]
a penalty for targeting hit the guy
right in the helmet if you know what I
mean with his foot
all right but the foot was only at waist
level huh are you smelling what The
Rock's cooking over here he kicked the
guy right in his [ __ ] dick
with his cleats on
I mean you know I don't know if that's
how you do it down there in Alabama
I don't know if somebody comes over and
says hey man I heard you're making some
moonshine and you're allowed to slide
across the wood chips on the [ __ ] bar
floor and bring your [ __ ] muddy boot
up to his [ __ ] nether regions
I don't know if that's how they do it
down there in Tuscaloosa but you don't
[ __ ] do that Foxborough
you don't do that in the NFL
I believe I was doing that Peyton
Manning show
when that was happening I wasn't on yet
and I saw him do it I heard Peyton go
whoop
I can't [ __ ] do that buddy
and then he's uh
through a pick six and he just [ __ ]
kind of went yeah
fortunately the Bengals quarterbacks
seem to see it coming
he kind of went Alfie sandwiches you
know he should be playing for the
Pittsburgh Penguins the way this he
could get into their Ring of Honor
I don't know I'm hoping it's like a
young immature frustration thing and but
I will tell you this I don't know how
much longer he can do that before
someone's gonna [ __ ] do it to him and
that ain't gonna be good at least that's
how it works out in hockey
in hockey
um all right
now that I've danced around the topic of
sports uh the thing I'm trying to avoid
because it's so [ __ ] sad uh the
passing of the legendary Franco Harris
man
I couldn't believe that when I heard the
news
I just done a show this
a few months back I don't know where it
was on the tour and I was with Joe
bartnick and Joe bartnick is a made man
in Pittsburgh
and he's in with those WDVE guys Randy
Bauman Bill Crawford and all of them
and um
bartnick hit me up and said hey man he
goes do you want to have dinner with
Franco Harris
and I was like what
he goes yeah man he goes he's into
comedy he wants to come to the show and
ask if you know if we wanted to go out
and have dinner and bartner was like I
met him before
and I was like are you kid absolutely
I still can't believe this happened
and um
we go out to dinner we're sitting at the
table and in walks Franco Harris
with his lovely wife and his son
and uh
just like
I don't know the first thing I noticed
about the guy was
how happy he was
how positive he was he's one of those
guys that just like lit up a room
big smile on his face
um
and then just sat down and told us all
of these stories like the like I maybe
said two words
I said more than that I was just asking
questions but like
and he loved telling stories he had so
many he took us through the whole
Immaculate Reception
um
remember bartnick did ask him uh what
was it like in practice
you mean you were practice against the
Steel Curtain what was that like and
this big grin came across his face and
he laughed and looked at his wife and
then looked back at us and he goes they
weren't allowed to touch me
but um
anyway so but I just was so blown away
by
um
you know aside from the fact it she
transcended that he was Franco Harris he
was just this amazing guy
and how happy and positive he was
and how full of life he was so when I
found out he passed I I couldn't I
couldn't believe it
um
because when I was sitting there talking
to him he looked like he had 20 years
left like that was the energy and the
vibe he had so
I the only upside I'm happy is that it
sounds like he passed him to sleep so he
didn't suffer
and um
I don't know if that guy and I was a
Cowboys fan back in the day
and um I still liked him but God damn it
he used to drive me nuts
was he oh because he was he was that
weird combination of he was really big
but he was fast so he could run over
guys or run past guys he could turn the
corner or lower his shoulder and um
almost like a hybrid like full back
slash running back and
um
I don't know I was a big Cowboys fan
back then and they always got the best
of us
even when we had it one like we did in
[ __ ] 78 oh my God we had that [ __ ]
game one
what's that [ __ ] guy bless his heart
he's got to be the sickest guy in
America
um anyway so
rest in peace to Franco Harris
um
so cool that they retired his number and
all that stuff but I I could not believe
um
you know if you were a fan of that guy
know that he you know right up to the
end
was super happy and super positive and
it was like something that I'm never
gonna forget where I was like I was
definitely you know
it's a weird thing when you're a young
person and you look at somebody in their
60s or 70s
you're just like wow that's an old guy
right but you get to be my age you look
at somebody in their 60s and 70s that's
not too far away from me so I look at
people
um and try to learn from people that
haven't let life
beat the [ __ ] out of them get them down
they're not bitter they're not [ __ ]
uh trying to be young they just still be
in them or whatever and they have like
this this Vibe that's incredible in um
Franco Harris definitely had that so
rest in peace to him and congratulations
to Franco from getting uh number 32
retired the Steelers do not do that
often so
um
yeah it's it it's sad but he's
I'm also I don't know
I'm just glad he didn't suffer or
anything like that because that guy was
just one of the nicest people I ever met
all right so there you go okay
uh rocket mortgage everybody
is a [ __ ]
Segway huh rocket mortgage you know if
your New Year's goal goals
are to manage your budget better and
save money you need rocket money
say goodbye to last year's outdated
disorganized methods of managing your
money in sail load or rocket money
what are we dealing Coke rocket money
the better way to hack your finances in
2023 rocket money
formerly known as true bill
I like that name better can I take that
name
hey everybody Welcome to Monday morning
podcast it's true bill true bill baby I
love you but you it's a personal finance
app that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps lower your bills all in one place
oh I love this [ __ ] all right rocket
mortgage these are the kind of guys that
can find [ __ ] like that rocket money
will quickly and easily identify your
subscriptions for you so you can stop
paying the ones
uh you don't want rocket money makes
canceling subscriptions as easy as a
click of a button
um simply find
the subscription you don't want and
press cancel and Rocket money will
cancel it for you I mean it can't get
any easier than that trying to cancel
those [ __ ] subscriptions is brutal uh
no more long-haul times with customer
service or tedious emails back and forth
yeah like they don't understand
that you want out of this relationship
Bally's Total Fitness
Valley's total [ __ ] that's what I call
them
um you get a full body workout on your
wallet no more long lines hold up over
three million people have used rocket
money saving the average person up to
720 bucks a year man
all right
that's a new acoustic guitar with the
[ __ ] amp you can an ovation from back
in the 80s stop throwing your money away
man cancel unwanted subscriptions and
manage your expenses the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com that's
rocketmoney.com rocketmoney.com
um Rockets r-o-c-k-e-t
not I.T all right greetings from Belgium
uh this is this is the letters from the
people out there that listen to the
podcast uh bill you make my life mellow
thanks
I make your life mellow
I think the weed's doing that brother I
don't know how mellow I am but I'll take
that you make my life mellow man uh when
are you coming to my [ __ ] country
called Belgium
I would love to go there I did Antwerp a
long time ago
I've never done Brussels
oh man if I went to Brussels and I ran
to Jean-Claude Van Damme he's like your
[ __ ] Crocodile Dundee
you know what I mean
like the most famous guy
and he [ __ ] that's not a knife that's
a knife he's like that's not a split
this is a split uh maybe I can take you
out for some beers take your wife it's
gonna be a blast wait a minute take my
wife what the [ __ ] does that mean
okay I don't drink anymore warm
greetings and happy holidays I see what
you're doing you like my wife I ain't
going there I'm going to Antwerp wait
that is in Belgium I was thinking
Brussels
I'll go to Luxembourg
take a tour of the Battle of the Bulge
uh no seriously I would love to go over
there
um
I would absolutely love to go over there
um I just have the kids now
so it's hard for me to be away
and I don't want to be away because my
kids are [ __ ] amazing and uh
that's it oh God I got my kid a fire
engine then he can like a little pedal
fire engine I ordered it actually came
from France
it's made out of nothing but metal and
wood
a few little plastic things the things
that you hammer on for the wheels you
know keep the wheels on but other than
that
um and he absolutely loves it
he's learning how to steer and stuff
it's just awesome
um anyway all right plowing ahead here
uh Bond Scott documentary
hey Billy the Kid big fan of your
podcast I just want to let you know that
there's a new and updated Bond Scott
documentary
what
you know some people are into like I got
a friend of mine like he's into like
Teddy Roosevelt
you know I got another friend of mine
he's into like the JFK conspiracy you
know I'm into like this type of [ __ ]
drummers
and [ __ ]
rock legend frontman
there's a new updated Bond Scott
documentary that has been released on
the Australian media viewing app called
ABC iview
says I'm Australian this is the first
time out of any of Bond's family
like this is the first time out of any
of Bond's family that have released any
personal information about his personal
life and his struggles along with AC DC
Etc I think you say this the first time
his family has actually gotten involved
which means they probably had
a little bit of creative control which
means this will be the most accurate one
which means I'm very excited right now
all right be sure to give it a watch as
I know you're a fan of him and a fan of
him in the band
I I that's this
it goes beyond that
I actually did a stand-up gig in Perth
Australia so I could go to Bond's grave
and pay my respects and when I got there
somebody had put a Miller Genuine Draft
on his on his you know next to his his
gravestone
and I was insulted for him
uh but I didn't remove it because you
know who knows it's weird you go to
another country all of a sudden that's
not a bad beer it's an import
ant
um all right be sure to give it a watch
as I know you're a fan of him uh P.S
come to Sydney us come to Sydney
Australia one day I would love to see
you live I have not been to Australia
since 2015.
and uh I am due to go down there
um even with the kids I think I could
blow through the country
six cities six days see nothing fly back
and be up all night when I got back here
I could still do that right
you notice it's 14 hours to get to
Sydney and then you got to get on
Another Place Another six hours
to Perth oh that's a [ __ ]
um
although it is pretty good when you put
your toesies in the Indian Ocean I will
tell you that and also uh the little
creatures
Brewery which was my favorite Australian
beer when I went over there when I was
still drinking oh my God I had two on
the day of a show which I never do
I sat there and they had like a uh they
had also they had a statue of bond Scott
that's how I stumbled upon it where they
had a statue upon Scott somewhere over
in that area
and it was Australia day and I got to
watch them all driving around in their
[ __ ] Australian El Caminos
shit-faced out of their minds it was
awesome
all right cameraman on the field
dear bronchitis Burr bronchitis upgraded
to pneumonia
you know what Nia's been calling me you
know you know Williams and Sonoma she's
been calling me William and pneumonia
ah she's [ __ ] hilarious
um and I know I gotta get her on the
podcast she reposted that thing I didn't
remember doing it singing that serial
killer silver bell song
um
and uh I don't know she's my favorite
person in the world to make laughs oh
well it's true all right myself and a
bunch of mass holes
drove five hours from Montana to see
your Ginger ass in the salt in Salt Lake
City last week awesome show oh thank God
you never know which way that's gonna go
we drove five [ __ ] hours you went
there with your [ __ ]
goddamn [ __ ]
um
awesome show worth the White Knuckle
drive through a snowstorm uh thanks for
taking the cold medicine and doing the
damn thing
yeah I didn't know which way that was
gonna go to see your [ __ ] woke so
I've been getting a lot of [ __ ] lately
people saying I'm woke whatever the [ __ ]
that I love that expression woke now
because that means something different
you know to every single person and then
I get these other people that just say
that uh you know
I'm a uh a Centrist and then other
people think I'm a conservative
um and what do all of those people have
in common jerk offs
all right any comedians listening to
this don't listen to these [ __ ]
[ __ ] trying to Brand what your
comedy is all right it's going into
their [ __ ] ear holes and into their
dumb brains and then it goes into the
the [ __ ] tumble dry with their whole
life experience or whatever the [ __ ]
their butthole heard about it and by the
time it comes out their [ __ ] mouth is
an idea it has nothing to do with you
you just look at them and you nod and
you [ __ ] move on and you continue
doing your [ __ ] the way you want to do
your [ __ ] all right oh
I put my pasty [ __ ] freckled foot
down on that one
um
let's see uh awesome show okay long time
fan here podcast listener just wanted to
throw a sports gripe at you can we get
these [ __ ] cameramen off the field
after points are scored
uh either football or baseball or
whatever there's always some cameraman
trying to jam himself into the action
getting in the way of the celebration or
running down the third Baseline like
they [ __ ] earned that Trot thankfully
these cameramen can't skate or fight or
we'd see them pushing a lens in
posturnox chipped teeth two to four
times a game go Sox [ __ ] the management
um yeah a lot of Red Sox fans not
enjoying the moves that we're making
not reciting Xander Bogarts
um
I don't know I would hate to be in their
position
because Santa Bogarts also wanted like a
contract the [ __ ] contract that the
Padres gave him that's definitely a win
now thing
you know what I mean in the end they're
going to be paying like nine zillion
dollars for a 39 40 41 year old
shortstop
but I think if you're the Padres the
Padres that makes sense because you've
never won one and you came so close last
year so I think the Padres that's a good
[ __ ] move I think for us it was a bad
move but it was also a bad move
that
I don't think he was looking for that I
think he just got that on the free agent
Market I think if we [ __ ] gave him
his Goddamn money back in March
we wouldn't had to try to match that
um
that's what I think haven't never even
[ __ ] coached a softball game
um
yeah those camerameness I don't need any
of that like the the uh the access I
don't need them talking I hate when they
talk to the coaches
you know they have like that um that
camera in The Dugout like during the
game
like a playoff game and something big
just happened and then like the guys in
the booth are talking to the to the
manager
um that's like way too much access for
me I would rather sit there and try to
guess what the guy's thinking
rather than seeing him having to uh
talk to somebody like I'm not into that
I would agree with you
um
all right [ __ ] spending
yo bill I stopped associating with any
party years ago
uh they're all [ __ ] in the head Oh I
thought you meant partying
[ __ ] spending I literally thought you
were like saying I quit drinking and I'm
saving all of this money
because I you know I went golfing this
past week
and uh played 18 holes you know a family
for back East was in town and
um
we went out to this legendary uh Golf
Course out here in LA
and uh I played 18 holes with the same
ball
didn't lose it one time I was bringing
the club almost all the way back I'm
sure you guys have seen my [ __ ]
granny swing
um I figured some things out with some
Club speed and that type of [ __ ]
and then of course right when I figured
I I thought I had it figured out I
started slicing
but uh you know
I was getting it off the deck pretty
good
um I mean I probably still shot
between I don't know
I'd say averaged about seven
on each hole
it's a fair number
that's a 70 and 56. yeah I think I broke
130.
all right
where are we now
all right
sorry I had to [ __ ] hack one up there
I'm not gonna lie to you
magic of editing you didn't have to hear
it all right [ __ ] spending yo bill I
stop associating with any party years
ago they're all [ __ ] in the head man
uh here's what was included in the 1.7
trillion dollar bill they passed two
days before Christmas
they all vote for it because they all
get something out of it
even if they think it's a waste because
a waste uh even I think it's a weight it
becomes a free-for-all here's some crazy
things in the build
um two hundred thousand dollars on
Starbucks
espresso machines for department for the
Department of Defense
Jesus you know what that'll buy you
about a hundred of them
this [ __ ] things are so expensive 2.3
million dollars to inject and test
cocaine on beagles
okay now that's fascinating because
we've already determined that it's not
good
why on beagles
and are they trying to do that Nazi
thing where you know the Nazis had some
of their troops on uh
methamphetamines and they didn't know
how to like you know after like three
days they would just be up for three
days and they would eventually go
bananas they go they go banana nuts
um
as Kyle Dunnigan says
are they trying to do like uh you know
like people do like
those micro dosings of mushrooms are
they trying to micro dose cocaine into
beagles
am I the only one who can't wait for
cocaine bear to come out
cocaine beagle the sequel I don't know
2.3 million I mean if they get the
[ __ ] rights for the sequel they can
make that money back
uh
um all right 1.1 million to watch mice
get drunk
why are these like really outdated you
think they would be doing something with
like parrot and meth
you know it's weird
uh
oh you can't you can't test meth on a
parrot they don't have any teeth uh six
eighty six hundred eighty nine thousand
to study the romance between parrots
holy [ __ ] right there
um
okay 118 000 to study whether or not the
character Thanos from the Marvel
movies
could snap his thumb in a metal
Gauntlet glove and make half the
universe disappear this is [ __ ]
what there's no way that last one was
real
can I hit you right in your helicopter
to a far away land thanks and Happy New
Year no because it can only fly for
about two hours and 45 minutes
so I could probably take you to Fresno
all right commercial Airlines landing
with autopilot oh here we go
here we go into the wild blue yonder
I'm Gonna Fly a lot in these next few
months I cannot [ __ ] wait once I get
past pneumonia
uh Williams and pneumonia commercial
airline Landing with autopilot dear Bill
VFR only Burr uh
I know that's haunts me and now I got
two kids I don't have the [ __ ] time
to do this uh on the money money podcast
a writer questioned single pilot
cockpits
uh you correctly stated that this is
inevitable and cargo carriers will get
approval soon the U.S Air Force's
experiment experimenting with this right
now and you can Google Air Force single
pilot cockpit
uh and read how we are flying aerial
refueling aircraft this way so getting
back to Landing in autopilot I think
this guy was eventually saying how
there'd be no Pilots up there aircrafts
that are category Category 3 certified
have an auto land feature
well what does category three is that
cargo carriers
um have an auto land feature where
autopilot takes it all the way to the
runway this is not complete commonly
used Pilots typically only engage it
when Landing in zero zero conditions
which would be perfect conditions no
wind
uh
in in
plus 10 statute miles visibility or
whatever the [ __ ] it is
so it's statute miles or [ __ ] old
lady miles takeoffs still are not done
in autopilot but there's no reason to
believe this won't be developed
now that you have free time start
cracking the books so you can fly IMC
like a real man all the best and go [ __ ]
yourself I will get my instrument rating
probably in my 60s with where my kids
are at at this point but I will get it
uh at some point I think I might just go
for my commercial this year it's
something easier it's something that I
can accomplish feel good about myself
and everything but I will tell you dude
after this past year
of
you know selling a movie
pre-production production
post-production and then also having to
write a new 90 minutes of material to
get ready for an arena tour before a
special came out uh and ending up with
[ __ ] pneumonia uh I don't think I'm
gonna go for that
I'm gonna get my little espresso do my
little French and I'm gonna hang out
with my kids
um
yeah I can't even tell you like
um how much I'm enjoying just being
around the house so that's what I'm
gonna do I'll leave the real man flying
to manly men like yourself I know what
you're doing though a nice little
[ __ ] negative jab you know how to get
me going
now it's bugging me I actually I'll tell
you this I actually really enjoyed it
that whole thing as much as
going through it and then my you know
getting super busy selling the movie
which is awesome obviously
but then my test expired and I got to
take that over again I will tell you
though I
you know I still have a you know the
little flight simulator
you know out here in my garage and uh I
get on that thing and I'm still pretty
good at it obviously it's not the same
conditions of actually doing it but
um
I [ __ ] totally get it
I love it and I'm fascinated by it and
even not getting it not getting the
rating how much I Learned was priceless
but that's definitely something I don't
think I'm gonna wait till my 60s it
[ __ ] bugs you [ __ ] [ __ ] why did
you bring it up it really bugs me
that I never got that done it really
[ __ ] bugs me so
um and typical me I don't go from
getting a private pilot's license to
getting a commercial and taking the baby
steps up I try to skip three stairs and
immediately go to that other thing I'm
gonna do the commercial and then I'm
gonna get the other one all right God
damn it
now you got that [ __ ] thing rolling
around in my head I'm actually glad you
did it but
um there you go that's the honesty of it
I try to play it off like it doesn't bug
me that I didn't accomplish that but it
really does bother me and what's funny
is I'm not allowed in in my helicopter
to ever fly in it anyway
but
um
I I God damn it I want that [ __ ]
rating there I said it all right
yeah I finally get three [ __ ] months
off where I wasn't gonna [ __ ] do
anything and rest my brain now you're
gonna have me going back to my
flashcards over there all right that's
it everybody I'm feeling much better
um I know I sounded like [ __ ] over the
last few [ __ ] weeks so I apologize
for that but uh I am on the modern
medication here so it's [ __ ] kicking
the [ __ ] out of it I am so elated
um
with what I did this year
um
you know as far as work I know I did
work too hard but I mean the experience
that I got working on the movie was
[ __ ] incredible and going around all
you guys showing up to my shows uh I'll
never forget it
and I loved every one of them from that
that Rodeo
facility I played in Boise Idaho
um
to Fenway Park I'm at Fenway point I
mean she was [ __ ] I had a [ __ ]
ridiculous year
and um
yeah yeah I put it I didn't need
anything for Christmas I didn't need
anything for Christmas and I still got a
Patriots stata jacket so I mean 2022 was
a great [ __ ] year
so to balance it out you get pneumonia
that's how it works all right go [ __ ]
yourselves uh I wish nothing but
wonderful things happiness and health
love anything you want in 2023
um
that's it all right go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll talk to you on Thursday